I'M AN AMAZING PERSON
WITH AN AMAZING LIFE.
- AND I'M LIZ.
I'M A COLLEGE GRADUATE
AND I EXPECT THE BEST.
I'M THE DRIVEN ONE.
- AND I'M TRYING TO HAVE A LIFE.
OUR PR FIRM
IS CALLED PUBLIZITY.
- IT'S BASED OFF
OUR NAMES.
IT'S REALLY AMAZING.
WELL, IT'S, LIKE, FUNNY BECAUSE,
LIKE, WE'RE VERY DIFFERENT.
- RIGHT.
- IT'S, LIKE, I LIVE TO WORK.
- EXACTLY.
AND I JUST WANT
TO HAVE AN AMAZING LIFE.
LIKE, THAT'S JUST ME.
I'M MYSELF.
- OKAY, THAT'S GREAT.
WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S--
MY POINT IS IT'S NOT JUST PEOPLE
THAT GET CANCER,
DOGS GET IT TOO--
- OH, MY GOD.
I LOVE DOGS.
- I LOVE DOGS.
- AND I WANT
TO RAISE AWARENESS FOR THAT.
THAT'S WHAT MY CHARITY IS FOR.
I HEAR YOU TWO ARE THE BEST.
- THANK YOU.
SO, LIKE, WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS, LIKE, A BIG PARTY.
LIKE, A BIG SPLASH.
OH, MY GOD!
I HAVE AN AMAZING IDEA.
- ALL RIGHT.
- PIRATE GIRL RUM PRESENTS
A ROCKING BEACH BASH
TO BENEFIT CUPCAKES
FOR CANINE CANCER.
- THAT'S CUTE.
- IT'S SUPER CUTE.
I'M GONNA WORK HARD
ON LOCKING DOWN
SOME CUSTOM CUPCAKES.
- [gasps]
AND MY NEW RESCUE DOG BRAD
CAN TOTALLY WALK THE RED CARPET.
I FOUND HIM IN THE TRASH.
- HE'S GROSS.
- YES, HE IS.
HE'S DISGUSTING.
- I JUST WANT IT
TO BE TASTEFUL.
- OH, MY GOD,
THAT'S SO COOL.
- THAT'S SWEET.
- THAT'S REALLY CUTE.
COMING UP NEXT
ON PUBLIZITY...
I LIKE TO WORK HARD.
- OBVIOUSLY, I KNOW HOW
TO DO MY LIFE.
LIKE, I'M 20-BLAH YEARS OLD
AND I KNOW WHAT TO DO,
SO THANK YOU,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
IT'S, LIKE,
JUST GO TO BED.
- WHERE THE [bleep]
IS LIZ?
[whining]